[Music]
hallo YouTube chess Louis in my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
second episode of my advanced chess and
game tutorials the position in front of
you has been reached between world
champion Magnus Carlsen and gosh EMU at
the second round of ember blindfold
rapid tournament and as you can see
Carlsen spawn is just to step away from
queening the reason why I'm showing you
this position is there is one important
concept / fundamental lies for such a
position and this is something very
difficult to find over the board
especially if you don't know about it
surprisingly enough in this game even
2700 plus rated super GM didn't know the
idea and blew up a completely drawn and
game so let's see what exactly it is
white place Queen to g7 blocking the
check and time being black plays a good
move Queen to e4 and we reach to the
critical position now the concept which
I am going to present in this video is
known as drawing zone which applies only
to either rook or the Knight pawn as you
can see I have highlighted those by the
arrows it can be described shortly as
follows a position when both the side
has Queen and one side has advanced past
rook or the knight born like here then
if black King can reach to certain
squares on the board then draw is in
avoidable before I reveal the concept I
urge you to setup this position on the
board and then play few moves as a black
against your friend or computer and see
if you can manage to get a draw
okay then let's start White's next move
is very obvious 0.287
and as you can see I have highlighted in
the green color the drawing zone for the
black ink so if white point is advancing
on edge or G file then drawing squares
for the blacking is even a2 and b1 b2
and if what is advancing the pawn on a
or B file then the drawing squares for
the blacking is H 1 H 2 and G 1 G 2
square now the first obvious question
comes to the mind is why are they known
as drawing square and what is special
about it well imagine that in order to
promote the pawn white King has to move
somewhere and then only way to draw the
game for black is to provide series of
Queen Jack and in many instant what will
block the check with his queen and this
is the vital point of this position as
the black King is far away the chances
of getting counter check are completely
suppressed compared to the king anywhere
on the board let me demonstrate this
with two scenario where black king is in
and out of the drawing zone so the first
scenario I am going to take case black
is managed to get into the drawing zone
and get a comfortable draw so here
accurate responses came to b3 and now I
can choose either of this moves it
doesn't matter because black King is
right on the time to enter into the
drawing zone a sample line can goes like
this quint web 7 check King to be 2
entering into the drawing zone and now
in order to promote that pawn white king
has to come out so let's say King to g7
and there are many ways you can check
the king I am just giving you a simple
line Queen to g4 check Queen to g6 Queen
to d7 check King 2 at 6 so the only way
for white to win this game is to somehow
take his king to the far end and then
block the Queen check with his own queen
and let's see how black encounter all
this so Queen to d2 check cringy phi
quinn d6 check king at phi quindi even
check quincy for queen h1 check and now
this is the problem case as white has
also need to taken care of the H born so
now King has to go back that is king to
g6 and in fact no matter how many done
step white king can take he can never
reach to the far end you can deliver
infinite number of check from this
position and the beauty you can already
see due to the superior drawing zone
position of the black King white cannot
deliver any counter check the second
move I can try over here is King to g8
but I think this is most easy one as you
can deliver this check and after Queen
to f8 you can give another check and
after King to h8 only thing you have to
be careful here that you cannot
immediately enter into the drawing zone
but you have an easy way and that is
king to c2 and now black is completely
fine in the next move he's going to
enter into the drawing zone and create
an easy trough probably this concept is
easy to understood by going through the
original game as in the game black
certainly doesn't have the clue of
drawing zone and he continues with King
to d3 which is a big time mistake as you
are going away from the trans own
it is very instructive to see how
calcine managed to win this game he
continues with Queen to d7 checking the
king and still black king should help
going towards the drying zone instead of
that he prefer King to e 2 which is
outright a big blunder and from here
onwards there is no escape white plays
came to g8 so creating a space for
another Queen and now black is forced to
give some checks so Queen to g6 happen
in the game white plays King to f8
quintet sex check Queen to g7 Queen to
f4 check Queen to f7 and now you can see
the drawback of poor miss placement of
this King black will allow to give all
these checks but the problem is White
Queen will come in between and it will
give a counter check to the black King
and that's why black has the only check
available in this position that is Quint
well 6 King to e7 Queen to h4 check King
to e8 Queen to f4 check and now the
winning move of the game wonderful King
to a fade which highlights how pathetic
this King position is as black would
like to give these checks but
unfortunately white queen will come in
between and black is going to lose the
game last desperate try by black Queen
to d4 trying to stop the queening but
this is now just an easy pie Carlsen
give this track and after king to f2 and
promoting the second Queen it is just an
easy technical performance required by
white only few moves has been played
Queen to d6 check King to f7
Queen to d7 check and after King to g6
black simply resigned as once again his
poor placement of the King annoy him and
he would love to give those checks but
in fact he cannot that's it guys I hope
with this short video you understand the
vital concept of drawing zone and
somehow if you stumble into this
position always remember this key aspect
which can help you to save a vital point
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care
you